Speaker 1: All right, I want to sort of just
close the loop on a couple of stories that
we've been talking about, the CEO of my pillow,
Michael Andell, who became a Trump friend
early during the pandemic and said Trump was
a gift from God.
And we thought that's probably as crazy as
this guy's going to get.
And then, of course, it got crazier and crazier.
Mike Lyndell, who claims that he has voting
machines in his possession, that same Mike
Lyndell, he is now sort of reversing the burden
of proof after saying he is going to be able
to prove that the election was actually stolen
by Joe Biden.
Now he's reversing it and saying he will give
you five million dollars if you can prove
to him that the election wasn't stolen, wasn't
stolen by Joe Biden, which is, of course,
a very, very different situation.
Business Insider reporting Mike Lendell is
offering five million dollars to anyone who
can disprove his allegations of voter fraud.
If they show up to his cyber symposium, he's
going to be doing the symposium in August.
Mike Lyndell, a staunch ally of Trump, leading
promoter of voter fraud conspiracy theories,
says he'd give five million dollars to anyone
who can disprove data that he claims shows
election interference.
But there's a catch.
To be eligible, you have to attend his upcoming
cyber symposium, which is taking place in
South Dakota between August 10 and 12.
So there's five million available guys, but
you've got to go to South Dakota and deal
with Mike Lyndell and people who support him
for three days.
And the event isn't open to the public, according
to an ad for the event posted on Lindley's
website.
Frank invitees include politicians, cybersecurity
experts and the media, though it will also
be streamed for 72 hours on Frank.
Lyndell said he wants the symposium to be
the most watched live event in history and
is aiming for a billion people to watch via
his website.
I can't imagine a billion people are going
to watch this.
He has reserved eight hundred rooms, but few
officials said they would attend.
There's also a really there's a funny other
thing to this, which is he wants media to
attend, but like normal reporters, they can't
take a free room from him.
They need to reserve their own rooms to maintain
independence.
And it's just standard protocol.
So there's actually reporters who have said,
in theory, I would go to this thing, but because
he reserved all of the rooms, I can't take
a free room from Mike Lendell because then
my reporting could potentially have been influenced
by the fact that I got a free room.
I'd have to say I got a free room, etc..
So he's almost shooting himself in the foot.
OK, here is a clip where Mike Lendell talks
about the five million dollars.
Speaker 3: Today, I'm putting up five million
dollars to any attendee that comes to them
that's invited to the symposium.
If they can prove that data is not the twenty
twenty two thousand twenty election.
Speaker 2: Did you just say five million?
Did you just say five million dollars?
That's correct.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So just the concept of burden of
proof, it's shifting from I have proof that
something happened to you.
Prove to me that it didn't happen.
As many of you know, when we've talked about
burden of proof and logical fallacies, proof
proving a negative can be very, very difficult.
And in fact, many conspiracy theories are
based on the fact that they put others in
a position of having to prove that X did not
happen, whereas really, if they are the ones
making the claim, they should be able to bring
us evidence that did happen.
One other really funny thing, and there's
a visual component here, which if you're not
watching, you're not you're not going to fully
appreciate.
There was this exclusive appearance that Mike
Lyndell did, I guess, on his own show where
he revealed the packet captures which prove
the election was stolen.
What you're going to see is there it looks
like the Matrix.
It's just long numbers scrolling up the screen.
It's of no meaning whatsoever.
There is no column headings.
Take a look at this and I'll describe it.
If you're just listening today,
Speaker 2: just this is this is big news,
Speaker 3: this business.
Why don't you I want you to put that once
again that we're announcing put those facts
inside that data back up there again and let
Speaker 2: it roll again.
Yeah, right.
Right against Rollings.
Right, right.
OK, right.
Speaker 3: I really want everybody to know
that this is you know, that this is what the
cyber guys this is the real deal here.
Everybody, this is first time.
Well, tonight, we had a show earlier, but
today
Speaker 2: from Today Brown, today is July.
Twenty second, third in July.
Twenty second, Thursday, July 22nd seconds.
Speaker 1: OK, so all that's happening is
numbers are scrolling up the screen like crazy.
And this is supposed to prove that Joe Biden
didn't really win the election.
And as if we need to take this seriously,
but some cybersecurity people looked at it
and again, it's like you don't really need
cybersecurity people to look at it, but there's
no column headings.
You can't match these numbers to anything
in particular.
They're not evidence of voter fraud of any
kind, never mind fraud.
That suggests it was actually Donald Trump
who won even a single state that he lost.
Like, it just doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
So anyway, if you want to go to South Dakota
between August 10th and 12th and I guess pay
to go, I don't know if you have to pay to
go or not to this symposium and then you can
prove that Joe Biden won or that there wasn't
fraud.
I guess better said there's five million bucks
in
it for you.